thank you so much for being on the
program uh this morning and if I may I
just want to start away from politics
um because six children under the age of
10 have died after developing the
infection strep hey I know this is
something that so many families can be
really concerned about
how worried should we be about her yes
and I think it's important to highlight
that the UK Health Security Agency uh
have said that in most cases it will be
mild
cases strep a but it is highly
infectious which is why I think the
important message to get across this
morning is parents should look out for
the symptoms so fever headache skin rash
that sort of feeling of the skin being
slightly rough
um really important to be vigilant
because in the very rare circumstance
that it becomes serious then you need
urgent treatment obviously uh yes
certainly um thank you for you know
giving the symptoms I know it's
something that you know definitely lots
of parents in particular will be Keen to
get the full information on
um now you're announcing today what you
describe as sensible contingency
measures in the event of public sector
strikes so what's the plan yes
absolutely well the first plan is to get
these strikes called off I think the
important thing to remember is Putin is
using energy as a weapon uh because he's
failing so badly in this illegal war in
Ukraine uh that energy use by Putin
means we've had very high inflation
rates and we've got to try and bring
down inflation if you chase
um inflation or above inflation in some
cases
um pay then you will embed inflation for
longer and hurt the most vulnerable in
fact which is our message to the unions
is to say you know this is not a time to
strike this is time to try and negotiate
but in the absence of that it's
important for the government it's the
right and responsible thing to do uh to
have contingency plans in place and uh
we have a very strong team at Cobra and
I was when I was in the uh seat of the
chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster uh
we were doing a lot of the work uh in
looking at what we need to do to
minimize the disruption to people's
lives whether you know it's unfair if
you're traveling at Christmas for for
you know the Border force or any other
Workforce to really disrupt people's
lives oh livelihoods and let's look at
the specifics are you talking about the
military being involved soldiers could
be driving ambulances so we're looking
at the military we're looking at a
specialist response Force which we've
actually set up a number of years ago
The Surge capacity to be able to deal
with uh in the unfortunate circumstance
if you do have say a striker border
force uh you've got to be able to make
sure that there is minimum disruption
the most important thing is just secure
it could be coming in filling some of
these roles because we have to make sure
our borders are always secure and that
is something that we guarantee and is it
the same in the NHS and again of course
in in things like driving ambulances
um other parts of the public sector
we've got to try and minimize uh
disruption but the way you
um try and deal with this is if the
unions can see that you're chasing
inflation
um uh or above inflation pay deal is not
the thing to do right now this is the
time to come together and to you know
send a very clear message to Mr Putin
that we're not going to be just just to
get divided in this way just just look
at the specifics um as well and are you
also looking at using pharmacists to
ease pressure on the NHS as the Sunday
Telegraph is reporting so perhaps
pharmacists being able to diagnose minor
conditions and even prescribe
antibiotics so the hope is obviously
that the NHS and uh if there is a
striking again I hope there isn't a
stroke uh say for example with the
nurses is that there is a minimum safety
level of uh delivery in place uh already
but the NHS will look at all contingency
planning to make sure that that patients
are able to get the urgent treatment
that they need so you could be looking
you could be looking at Pharmacists
playing a bigger role well the NHS will
will make sure that we we have to be
able to deliver a safe level of
treatment and support to patients
um at all times and I hope again I I
would put it back to the unions himself
to say one we shouldn't be striking if
you look at what uh the uh pay review
bodies for the NHS recommended we've
accepted that recommendation uh in fact
last year when pay was Frozen
um nurses got a three percent pay raise
they do an incredible job of course I
understand that but to ask for 19 pay
rise which cost the NHS 10 billion
pounds I think it's it's the wrong thing
to do right now I do want to come back
on this as well because you know you're
talking about not chasing inflation for
lots of people who are on low-pay jobs
they're not chasing inflation they're
trying to get a pay that is matching the
cost of living because they're looking
at their shopping Bills going on they're
looking at their energy Bills going up
they want to pay to be reflecting how
much more they're having to spend on
things it's not about embedding
inflation for them it's about surviving
of course and absolute which is why the
chancellor came to the dispatch box and
delivered a 150 billion pound energy
package that's this by the way if you
you take that into equivalence that's
equivalent of the whole of the NHS to
support people's households otherwise
their energy bills would have uh spiked
to support businesses as well the money
we're putting into helping those most
vulnerable uh the 8 million most
vulnerable households is significant we
have to come together this is not a time
to be divided to our hopes and a very
clear message to Mr Putin that he can't
use energy as a weapon in this way and
we will remain United which is why we've
accepted accepted the pay-per-view
bodies I guess NHS I guess and on
schools on 20 grand a year you would
think that maybe there are other ways of
sending Putin a clear message on Ukraine
rather than the fact that you're going
to have to well no we have a real term
but no but we've accepted the the pay
review body on nurses and as I said to
you last year they got three percent the
this year's recommendation is 1400
pounds so the uh you know the starting
salary of a nurse would be a 31 000
pounds it is difficult I am absolutely
you know con is the fact of how hard
things are at the moment but it's not a
time to you know go for 19 pay rise that
will cost 10 billion pounds because if
you you know if you accept all the
inflation level pay Rises that's about
28 billion pounds it costs every
household just short of a thousand
pounds
um that is you know unsustainable when
we're trying to be fiscally disciplined
and bring inflation under control
because if inflation is embedded it'll
hurt those families those nurses even
more in the long term now I want to talk
about immigration
um because we've seen record levels of
immigration record numbers of small
boats crossing the channel as well
um many people voted for brexit to be
able to control Britain's borders are we
in control of them so on illegal
migration small boats and these gangs
that are preying on the vulnerabilities
putting lives at risk
um we have a plan the Prime Minister
within weeks are we in control of our
borders well of course we are in control
of our borders but there is an issue
around these small boats and these gangs
and illegal migration and the Prime
Minister within weeks of taking power
signed an agreement with France to
increase uh the number of patrols by I
think about 40 percent which will help
on this uh they've already turned back
about 30 000 uh people who would have
come across the numbers are still far
too high I I recognize that and again I
spent some time in the cabinet office
looking at this we are determined to
deal with it this prime minister
determined to deal with it they're at no
easy solutions but there are a number of
things that we can do including
operationalizing Rwanda uh to actually
send a very clear message to these you
know gangs that this will not work and I
think the moment that happens you'll see
the numbers is begin to drop rapidly as
we saw when when if you remember under
Theresa may we dealt with the issue of
people coming across uh being smuggled
in in trucks talking about and reduce
that and took it to to near zero so it's
important to focus on it and then on
legal migration uh we need to make sure
that we you know focus on if there is
any abuse of the legal migration system
if there are people you know for example
um our universities do a brilliant job
and it's a great export for the UK
people are coming here doing their phds
and their masters and creating you know
new Innovative things for the British
economy but if there's an abuse of the
system then we should stamp that out as
well so you are looking then at reduced
the number of foreign students coming to
University no I didn't say that okay um
what I said to you is Forest students
coming to our universities are a great
export these are you're really really uh
important to us and of course our
economy okay
um to our really high quality
universities but if there is abuse and
there was in the past I remember some
time back you know bogus University
setting up understanding the Kebab shops
on them illegal migration because there
was another question I was Keen to
squeeze in on this and there's a report
by Nick Timothy who of course was the
chief of staff to Theresa May who
recommends Banning people who enter the
UK through illegal routes from ever
settling in the United Kingdom they
should not be a need for people to come
through on an illegal uh route because
if you have a legitimate right
um to settlement to Refuge then you
should be able to settle here and it's
right that we should address the issue
of illegal so you are potentially
considering Banning people who enter the
UK legally from ever well look that's an
issue that's the question for the Home
Secretary what I'm saying to you is
we've got to deal with the gangs that
are exploiting people putting lives at
risk on these small boats and I am
absolutely certain that the Prime
Minister and the Home Secretary are
focused on this no easy answer is but we
will absolutely deliver against this in
the weeks and months to come now I want
to talk to you with your party chair at
hat on if I may you know you're
responsible for campaigning you've got a
big role in election planning as well so
I just want to look at the states of the
conservative party right now you know
this is the current tracker poll from
you go if you can see there has been you
know a slight narrowing I guess at the
polls but it's been nothing like you
know a big bounce for Rishi sunac
um Labor's still well ahead and of
course if these polls were replicated in
an election it would be cursed armor in
Downing stream How concerned are you so
when you ask people and I know a little
bit about polling because I founded Hugo
well here you go but it must be it's a
bit awkward looking up your company
pulses including you go but if you
actually look beneath the headline a
couple of things I would pull out uh
from that one when you ask people the
question if there is an election
tomorrow how would you vote well people
know there's no election tomorrow so
that response what you're seeing is
currently there how they feel about the
the the government's track record on
delivery now we know we've had a
difficult time you know we've had a
difficult time I've been on uh this show
and other shows having to explain why
we're you know uh going through this
sort of difficult period in the
Parliamentary party uh and in our
leadership
um we're in rebuilding mode now to make
sure that we you know be
ready and fit for purpose for the local
elections next year and then for a
general election in 2024. uh now if you
dig beneath the data I'd be worried if I
was kissed armor because you'd be
worried if you're okay
if you'll allow me right if you if you
look at his numbers it's very soft
there's not a great passion for what
Kirsten certainly there's no passion for
him when he went before the Trade union
Congress saying he'll repeal all of the
Trade union legislation that the
conservatives have brought in he's made
that promise and if you ask that same
people is that a good thing or a bad
thing I think most of them will say it's
a bad thing but we are in a rebuilding
exercise we've got to rebuild that trust
with the public so that began with the
chance of exchequer and the Autumn
statement to deal with inflation when we
bring inflation back under control in
the back of England that's independent
we'll do that they have all the tools
available to them but we have a
responsibility to help them because we
have physical responsibility to do that
when we've done that when we've
delivered on Innovation that 20 billion
investment we've delivered on skills
when we've delivered on the
infrastructure that people want to see
in their constituents and small boats
it's a real problem for us right then
you'll see those numbers move in the
right direction I'm confident of that
and if you can't deliver on things like
small boats we will that's my point
about rebuilding is it true that cchq is
now ranking conservative MPS on how many
leaflets they deliver and how many doors
they knock on apart according to the
times they use Theresa May as an example
pointing out that she's out twice a week
is that right I like all candidates all
MPS as they do themselves by the way to
be out on the doorstep knocking on doors
engaging with their constituents it's
the right thing to do who's the best
performer well there's lots of great
performers and you will see by the way
the phones are ringing at cchq people
have come back people are supporting us
the atmosphere in the building I think
is incredibly positive and as I said to
you we will continue to build we've got
local elections great councilors great
candidates for local elections uh next
May and then of course for the uh
election whenever the Prime Minister
comes it's interesting because you're
talking there about the positive
atmosphere in cchq and I have to say and
if you take a step back and look at the
country right now the conservatives of
course been in power for 12 years we've
got record any waiting times we're
spending more on debt interest payments
than education whether it's the time
you're waiting to book a driving test or
the backlogs in the court you know it
feels like this is a country that is
breaking at the seams you know why would
anyone vote for the conservatives who've
been in power presiding over this well
because
I was close to this we delivered the
most successful vaccination program
in this constitutional history probably
in the world where we've protected the
nation and you see what's happening in
countries today look at what's happening
in China vis-a-vis dealing with the
pandemic today we've dealt with that
pandemic during that period Rishi sunak
as Chancellor this exchecker to put over
400 billion pounds to work to protect
people's livelihoods and of course jobs
we've done it again just now because
Putin is using energy as a weapon 150
billion pound energy package three
million businesses protected that would
have gone to the wall perfectly viable
because we know as well that the
household that would have struggled 150
billion pounds of additional help for
people if you take all of that that has
to be paid for right then of course we
have the recovery the NHS has to recover
from the pandemic that is happening now
we've dealt with a two-year waiting list
by next April we'll deal with the 18
month waiting list and of course we've
got a a package for Christmas at the
moment to make sure the NHS gets through
Christmas a 500 million package to get
people into social care a big investment
in Social care all these things are
happening but
the onus is on us to demonstrate to the
public to show by doing particularly
that is what we're doing particularly
because we just had a conservative prime
minister who crashed the economy became
the shortest serving PM ever and had a
u-turn on her entire budget well I'm
going to repeat what Jeremy Hunt said
the chancellor he said you know that
mini budget was reversed within three
weeks even the obr would say to you that
that's not the impact on the economy the
obr in fact said the office for Budget
responsibility the impact on the economy
is because of Putin's and they have also
said they all they have also talked
about the impact of the mini budget but
they said they're not purely but they
said the international factors
you're quite right but they said the the
predominant okay bulk of the impact okay
was because of Putin using energy as a
weapon we mustn't forget that Wellness
has a price and we have to continue to
support Ukraine and Vladimir zielinski
because this illegal War has to end with
Russia leaving Ukraine there are reports
uh that some conservative MPS believe
that Boris Johnson may still be the
answer to your election issues shall we
say here's Stephen swinford in the times
Boris Johnson supporters are convinced
that sunac will fall and that Johnson
will replace him with the May local
elections seen as a focal point you know
you're obviously back to sports Johnson
to be a leader do you still speak to him
I speak to Boris Johnson I in fact I
spoke for him in his constituency he did
a conversation with the chairman of the
party let me tell you what Boris Johnson
thinks as he did when he reflected and
stepped aside and supported Rishi sunak
he said I will not be selfish I will put
country and party ahead and Rishi has
the overwhelming support of the
Parliamentary party which is why he
supported him that was the right thing
to do we have to remain United we've got
local elections coming up next year and
we've got a whole delivery program on
health of course on education and of
course safer streets and small boats
that we've got to deliver against that
is what Boris Johnson is focused on at
the moment okay no chance then he'll
he'll come back as leader no because
having another leadership election will
be a Surefire way of us losing uh in
elections okay
um one question that I just want to ask
before we finish
um which is about the allegations around
a conceptive at MP and the victims we
understand or alleged victims haven't
made formal complaints but a number of
conservative MPS have made
um complaints or reports about this
person's alleged Behavior
should they be suspended from the
conservative party well this is a very
important safeguarding question and I
the moment I walked into the building at
conserve headquarters I asked
independent for independent legal advice
on this issue as well as our own
in-house legal
advice on the case we also spoke to the
house authorities we spoke to the
priority ethics
team on this and it is up to the police
because these allegations are third
party allegations that have been handed
to the police we've spoken to the I
spoke to the police as well of course
and if the police decide to take action
then of course we will take action as
well okay uh just finally
England playing later today indeed are
you gonna be watching of course is it
coming home
it will I'm not going to sing that song
or go anywhere near it because every
time I've done that it has broken my
heart okay thank you very much indeed
for being on the program